okay y'all
let's go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome to
your favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome to episode
200 of riften with griffin
got a special one for you got the wifey
on
and then i'm gonna do like you know
stuff that i normally do which is you
know
got my reviews she-hulk uh house of
dragons
and a few other things so
welcome back
i appreciate you guys being here i
appreciate all the support
once again
thanks for being here
[Music]
[Music]
all right yeah there we go
um yeah that's the riffing with griffin
theme song back at it again love it so
much uh you know so uh hey
welcome to riffin with griffin guys uh
as you know yes we're from with griffin
hit that main titles again riffing with
griffin
episode 200 with rachel
[Music]
pow so i recorded it earlier with rachel
downstairs on the couch so i'll play
that video but right now we're live
and remember uh
you know subscribe thank you for
subscribing hitting the notifications
you know doing all that helping the show
grow
uh remember i'm on twitch daily uh you
know i still out there gaming that's
another way you can support the shows
you could be a stretch subscriber you
could be a youtube member
or you can even go on patreon uh you
know i have some videos ready to go on
there too you know what i mean so
uh
you know what i mean so i appreciate
that and you know it you know if you
have um you know if you're gonna be
negative on the chat i'm just gonna you
know remove you you know i don't need i
don't need your [ __ ] so bye
you know what i mean
so i already see some [ __ ] i already
see some negativity i don't need it go
go uh go live your life someplace else
where somebody cares
uh you know what i mean so anyways
fishy beets is in the house thank you
fish or some some dope beats to come you
know when we do the
chat we do the rap recap but first uh
let's uh get into this we got to pay
some of the bills from for some of the
sponsors of the show today's show first
up is helix sleep helix is offering up
to 200 off all mattress orders now two
free pillows for our listeners go to
helixly.com griffin with helix better
sleep starts now
also
draftkings y'all draftkings download the
draftkings app now and use promo code
riffin
to get 200 and free bets instantly when
you place a five dollar bet this sunday
that's code riffin only at draftkings
sportsbook and official sports betting
partner of the nfl minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply see show
notes for details
okay
welcome back to roofing with griffin uh
you know man you know it's
when i when i introduced rachel later in
the in the thing you know it was like i
say this but i didn't mean to make it
sound like this so i'm just saying it
now so you know what i mean it's like i
had asked a bunch of people
in the lat in like the last month be
like hey can you do the podcast can you
do the podcast it's my 200th episode
everybody's busy everybody's doing
something else every so i just got to
run around from so many people you know
and so i was like damn i'm not gonna
have like so i wanted to have like you
know somebody you know like oh man uh
big on the thing it's just everybody it
fell through and then i was like you
know well who can i get and i thought to
myself well you know who i'll get i'll
just get rachel she hasn't been on in a
while we got marriage we haven't talked
about it it's just i like talking to her
and it's like she's great to look at
you know what i mean on the screen
and uh we have fun conversations so i'll
play that for you guys live
uh later so but you know
she's like oh sorry that i'm not a big
gas that's what she says on the thing
it's kind of funny but um
[Music]
you know so what's going on uh with me
man uh you know i just been uh
doing my thing man you know i'm just i'm
starting to do some traveling like if
you are
if you are um going to be in the san
diego area
i will be
at the la jolla comedy store 9th through
the 11th come check me out that's this
weekend in la jolla so if you're there
and uh shout out to fishy for this dope
fishy beat as we gonna be our official
this is where i'm gonna be this weekend
beat so
there's that so make sure you guys come
check that out i'll be there if you want
to come out and watch me and i'll be in
milwaukee the week after but i will make
a new one for milwaukee next week
so
huh man um
what's been going on i you know what's
crazy is i was talking to like a friend
of mine who i hadn't talked to in a
while you know because i hadn't seen
them online whatever you know and i was
like yo what's up like where you been
what's going on and like you know this
you know i just really have a problem
talking to
my younger friends this genera that
generation of people that are like late
20s you know early 30s these kind of
people
like the way they
communicate online you know it's like
y'all think yo like
all y'all do is spend all your time
online yeah yeah you're posting you're
stewing stories you know you're always
like here's where i am here's this and
here's that you know and then at the
same time
trashing social media like
so many of this just this younger
generation they like to use social media
and then turn around and be like oh i
need a break from social media and you
know that this
it's not real you know that's what they
that's how they talk about it's not real
and you know then they want to like
remove themselves from it you know
they're like okay well i'm not going to
be on for a while but at the same time i
hit my friend up and i'm like yeah where
you been you know
and they're like um
yeah i just you know i removed i i just
i remove myself from instagram and i'm
just you know i i'm not responding to
people but then at the same time says i
feel alone
you know i feel alone in la you know
like
what like like what did they say like i
want to see you know
it's it's it's such a weird
it's such a weird thought process
to be like you know and i don't want to
be like an old crotchety dude because
that's not what it is but when somebody
says i'm feeling better i'm just really
lost
and it's hard to not feel invisible in
this city you know that was the words
that were used i'm like well
if you're hiding
and not responding to people then yeah
you're going to be invisible but you're
not invisible if people are actually
looking for you if your friends and
family and people are trying to reach
out to you and you're not responding
well then yeah you're going to be lost
because you're playing hide and seek
my other friend puts up this post on uh
instagram talking about uh
um
what was it like
oh you know the the you know social
media isn't real you know like one of
those things i'm like why are you always
on it it's like you know what really
ticks me off about
this is what takes me off about the
young people like my young friends they
want to talk about being invisible they
want to talk about not you know social
media isn't real but then when you hit
them up real
like if you send a text or you send a dm
now because that's how they communicate
you know like they're all apps by the
way imessage
the text app is just an app
when you say direct message
guys that's what a dm is it's a
direct message you know what
imessages
is a direct message so you know you try
to hit up these people you go so they
you see them online all the time so you
go hey what's up and then you know they
don't get back to you you get a little
bit of an attitude you're like yo what's
up i've been hitting you up
oh i mean that's on social media that's
not real you know like it's like that's
the the sentiment of like oh well you
know you're hitting me up there oh so so
let me use this other app so the other
app it's more real there
and it's like
if if you think that social media is
fake if you think that the internet is
fake if it's like just a highlight of
your life
when real people are hitting you up get
back to them get back to your friends
and family they hit you up
i mean it's so annoying to text your
friend you know what the most annoying
thing is when you text somebody and they
don't get back to you
but you see that they on instagram all
damn day you know what i mean
how
it's like what are you talking about you
you in instagram all day
so you you know you spend the time doing
that and then trashing it and then when
your real friends are trying to be like
hey how are you you don't want to
respond to that i just
it's just something i'm
i don't want to be get off my lawn guy
i'm just trying to understand it okay
i'm just trying to understand it y'all
so
help me understand it in the comments if
you're like a millennial you're you know
late 20s early 30s and you communicate
like this
tell me like
what is the older generation
need to do because y'all don't
understand how it used to be
like
you know we used to have to like honk
our horn when we went to pick you up
because or get out of the car and go
knock on the door we just have to call
on a real phone and be like hey i'm on
the way or we'd be like yo what's up
that's how we talked with each other so
my generation still has a little bit of
that in that's how we communicate that's
how we talk even when we text we talk
like that even when we text we're talk
like we want to have a beginning middle
and end to the conversation this
generation is just kind of like you're
just talking you're just like hey how
are you and then it's just there for
five six days and then you don't even
hear from this person and then you know
when you're kind of like have an
attitude about it like yo what's up
they're like oh well you know
well
my my
people from my era we have a problem
with that
so i'm just doing this
if i text somebody two or three times
and they don't get back to me
bye
i'm just gonna remove their number i
just i remove them from my address book
i go to like
instagram whatever unfollow you on fi i
unfollow i remove follower unfollow
we're gone and so then i know okay hoof
let me just get that person out because
i'm the kind of person i feel like if
you really are my friend i'm gonna try
to
i try to be like hey what's up how are
you what's going on hey i remember this
thing you were going through hey what's
going on with this but it's like
i don't think the generation really
wants that i think they just want to
display it online but they don't really
want to deal with it if that makes sense
um you know
so i don't know
i mean i see somebody in the comments
talking about when you realize that
somebody isn't struggling call them
don't send them a text i just i disagree
completely uh you are you are completely
wrong about that because that's just
rude nowadays you know you know what you
should do you you do have to check in
with people i do think it's i do think
it's safe to be like
send a text hey
why what's going on
i hear you're not doing well let me give
you a call like announce that i think
that's important to announce you know
uh you know what i mean i just i just
think that that's okay this is you know
we have to move with the times too like
you know you can't just like when
somebody calls me i'm kind of like what
you're calling me for i don't even know
you like that you know
especially like some of these apps just
allow people to call you and stuff like
i think that's ridiculous that's crazy i
block anybody that tries to like
snapchat these kind of things i just
block them i'm like you don't know me
like that why are you calling me you
know so it's like you know it's that
kind of weird you know that kind of
weird vibe
so anyways that's that that was just
like my oh that's the old crotchety
bitching with griffin segment of uh
you know how that's going and welcome
welcome all you people that are here
live and i want to thank all the members
my my small little youtube members
family and all my all my patreon people
i want to thank you for the support i
was a very small
small but mighty crew of members and all
the twitch guys all the people all my
like i have over 100 something subs on
twitch i appreciate you guys there and
if you want to see me all the time like
twitch is the best place to go for that
because i'm i'm starting to like make my
videos on twitch live and then put them
on patreon and the youtube member
youtube for also for the youtube members
so that's that so before i get to the
rachel stuff i just thought you know
what let me just get into uh some of
this uh some of the the the things that
were going on i'll tell you something
and i i put this on my instagram already
earlier like earlier this week but i
want to talk about it again here on the
podcast i'm a huge big brother fan okay
a huge big brother fan i don't know if
i'm gonna be watching it too much
anymore because something just happened
and it just really take me off man so
you know they have you know i don't know
if you don't know what big brother is
it's like 16 to 20 people they move into
a house they have to lie connive steal
mislead not steal but they have to live
connive each you know mislead each other
they have to basically betray each other
for 750 000 in the end okay that's what
the game it's a psychological experiment
and that's what happens all right
for the last 25 years they've been doing
the show it's mostly white you know it
just is what it is
it's just majority of the people on the
show are white all right that's just a
fact okay
most recently they've now they've like
really with the push for diversity and
not just with race with different sizes
and and you know you know it'll be fat
and old and all this kind of stuff i'm
against that because they set them up
for failure because it's endurance
competitions a lot of the stuff is
physical endurance competitions and you
got a fat girl out here running an
obstacle course and she can't do it or
he can't do it or it's an old guy that's
like you know so i i have a problem with
that because of the nature of the show
but whatever it is what it is
last year on big brother
they had the most black people i think
that's ever been on the show the black
people look around at each other and
they go you know a black person has
never won big brother
why don't we have an alliance a secret
alliance so we can ensure that the final
seven is us there's seven black people
let's make an alliance
and it was masterful what they did i
mean it really was it was the greatest
big brother alliance ever they cleaned
out the rest of the house and it was
them left and they fought it between
each other and sure enough someone black
won big brother cut to now this year
okay
this year the things about the show is
expect the unexpected they say that
nonsense all the time expect the under
expected anything can happen right
so you cut to this kind of like goofy
white guy named kyle and he's goofy you
know what i mean good looking athletic
dude but the way he talks he's a little
goofy he don't seem that world he's
young okay
anyways he
brings up to two other
white contestants one of them's gay and
the other one's a a woman a chubby woman
so just to put in context that they are
already like outsiders in terms of and
he's talking to them just to be like hey
i'm getting a sense that
there's three like ethnic people who are
like he knows that they're a group and
there's another people who are group
he's just
he's just talking it out like could that
be happening again like what happened
last year in the cookout
that was the name of their alliance
could this be happening again he's just
bringing it up
one he knows he's on national television
he knows it's being filmed 24 hours a
day he's not an idiot
he's bringing it up in a certain way it
was clumsy the way he was talking about
it but i didn't get a sense that the
dude was a racist i got a sense that to
do was just an idiot all right but it
was fair of him to be like i wonder if
that's happening again okay like there's
always all girl alliances there's always
all guy alliances nobody has a problem
with that uh you know what i mean and so
for the first time they had an all-black
alliance last year because it's never
been done so this guy's coming this year
and being like yo
man
they brought it up and they painted the
dude as a racist and it pissed me off
man
in a game that you're supposed to lie
steal cheat betray you're supposed to do
all this stuff to each other to for
money you're supposed to like connive
and you know all of this stuff you're
supposed to like mislead and then so in
a game like that it's not out of pocket
for this white dude to be like i wonder
if the minorities are doing this again
it's game he was just talking game and
all the sort of virtue signaling
nonsense that was happening on the show
two middle fingers up to big brother man
that's how i feel about it
and when those people get out the house
they gonna they gonna look bad i hope
they look back on this and be like oh
man what were we doing i mean they were
basically they were gaslighting this
dude into thinking he was a racist and
it was just shameful it was shameful and
we gotta stop that's all i have to say
about that all right
and real quick uh let's get into um what
is this right here oh let's let's talk
about this one here so i want to keep up
with you know
i really want to do this on my patreon
and stuff and moving forward but you
know she-hulk last two episodes didn't
talk about it last week
you know what i got to say man i really
like she-hulk and i think that it's it's
it could be better than it actually is
because when you think about it it's
like 20-minute episodes man you're not
getting enough it's basically just a lot
of special effects and cameos from like
you know i don't know what story they're
telling i don't know how there's some
through line to keep everything together
i mean i like the fact that she's a
lawyer and it's great that she's a
lawyer for supers you know like so
something's happening in the super
natural world you know so it's kind of
like
a comedy and like you know it was like
it just to me it just seemed real cheesy
and corny and not long enough they got
like it seems like they got
10 minutes of end credits where there
could be show
i don't understand why there's so many
end credits on these disney
shows man disney plus shows makes no
sense to me there's these opening
credits and there's like like literal
like i'm not even exaggerating dude it's
7 to 10 minutes
of this 30 minute show of end credits so
i think the show's kind of like
i don't know i don't like it
i don't like that i think that like
they're leaving a lot of meat on the
bone and
i wish that i hope they delve into
something more to really make us uh you
know keep us keep us around man but for
now it's just
you know i mean they had it's just it
just feels incomplete man feels
incomplete
house of dragons house of the dragon see
episode two and three have been out i
still like this show but i'm starting to
feel like
it's like man i know too much about
uh you know the future of you know you
know what i mean like
i wish it was
about more than what it's about
i've said this before i said it on king
of sting i've said it on my podcast
earlier
like
so you could have magic you could have
dragons you could have black people with
blonde hair but you but but women still
can't run stuff like that's the show
that's the narrative of the show like
and i'm just kind of like ah
so i don't know they're doing a time
jump where
the [ __ ] the king now has you know the
king you know got hit his daughter's
best friend pregnant you know so now
she's the queen and has is pumping out
babies so he named him her the heir but
like you know you know it's coming you
know he got a son you know what i mean
and i think the son's name it reminds me
i feel like i know the name of this son
and it's like i feel like this is we
heard about this but i couldn't be
because it's 172 years so i'm starting
to get bored of game of this of this uh
show
i mean i would have rather have it been
about something you know completely
different like there's not enough to me
there's not enough characters
there's not enough intrigue there's not
enough like you know backstabbing you
know it should be more like big brother
really
so i don't know man i don't know how you
guys feel about it
you know i don't know how you guys feel
about it but because you know this is
another thing too is like they set up
this whole thing where this crab guy is
killing the shipping lines and he's like
you know feeding people to the crabs and
then episode three they kind of just you
know
tied that up and then now you're like
what
so this is so now the show basically
has turned into the idea of like is this
guy's brother
is he gonna take the throne is he gonna
give the throne to his daughter or is he
gonna give the throne to his son and
then what happened to the king's
sickness remember how his pinky was all
getting worn away and he had something
on his back so i felt like were they
telling us that because he might end up
dead he's gonna die and then it's gonna
be this turmoil about who's going to be
king and like you know what i mean like
it's just you know i don't know
it started off strong but i gotta say
i'm getting a little bored of it because
the original
to this the original first three or four
seasons it's way better than this
it's way better than this i like the
main girl i think she's good but like
but it's like okay she was she's
starting to remind me too much of the
first one you know the you know
kind of a little blonde girl who's a
badass i'm like oh okay so we have to
keep that going so i don't know guys i
don't know how you feel about it um
we'll see you know i started somebody
asked me right now hey griff have you
ever considered reading the books i did
you know what i read the first book
and i really loved how the show
was closely following the books more
than i've seen
any other show you know before
and then they went off the rails you
know then they kind of like did their
own thing and that's just kind of what
happens because it's harder to like you
know the books are so extensive
you know but the thing about you know
the thing that this show's missing i'm
gonna tell you what this show is missing
so far who's to say that it's not gonna
happen but i'll tell you what this
show's missing so far compared to the
first show
the first show
they didn't care who you were
you could die like this
i loved that
the the red the red wedding
season
that dude was on the poster for the show
and they killed him
i love that
in the first season of game of thrones
they killed off this main character
and it really set the tone for like oh
man
anybody could die at any time
they haven't done that in this show yet
i kind of well you know what i mean like
we're starting to get to know some of
these characters so i need one of them
to get offed so we could be like oh this
this this is this is the world man so
we'll see
so i don't know but anyways that's how
i'm feeling about
that's how i'm feeling about uh that so
far about she-hulk and uh game of
thrones season episode one and two
uh she-hulk's getting a little boring
it's getting a little like not
necessarily boring but like not enough
and and game of thrones house of the
dragon is it's getting a little
monotonous now about the same through
line so it's like what's really
happening what's going on here because
it's hard to unknow that we know where
this is going
you know like i would like to see like
this is the intrigue that happened
in this particular time frame but it
just feels like it's not important
enough
if that makes sense
don't feel important but anyways guys um
let's uh pay
some
bills one of the bills and one of the
bills i want to pay is you know or make
some love let's talk about down you know
download the draftkings
sports app it's the official sports
betting partner of the nfl i'm super
excited about the nfl season i got my
fantasy football team and football is a
great sport to bet on because it's real
simple it's once a week you can bet on
who's going to win and all that kind of
stuff and and that's why i love that the
first sunday of the nfl season is here
and like i said the official sports
betting partner of the nfl is giving new
customers a can't miss offer to
celebrate the return of the nfl season
right now new customers can get five
dollars and get 200 in free bets
instantly and as an added bonus for week
one
everyone can experience the thrill of
king's early win promotion
early win promotion goal it's simple bet
on nfl team to win if your team leads by
10 at any point during the game you get
paid instantly
damn i love that even if your team loses
so your team just got to get up by 10.
uh so you know i love that i play
draftkings like even with my fantasy
football guys we have like a draftkings
thing that every week we'll put a little
bit in and you know and see who
who who's going to come out ahead with
you know who's going to win the little
pool that we do so draftkings
is great but anyways guys download the
draftking sportsbook app now and use
promo code riffin that's r-i-f-f-i-n to
get two hundred dollars in free bets
instantly when you place a five dollar
bet this sunday that's code riffen only
at draftkings sportsbook an official
sports betting partner of the nfl
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details
all right
and once again if you don't remember
this is riffing with griffin this is
episode 200 with my beautiful lady
rachel griffin my beautiful wife so we
recorded this earlier and i will play
this for you now enjoy
i moved the pillow earlier because i
woke up at 6 a.m
and then i came downstairs to watch tv
the pillow was in my way
yeah
all right
sorry did it hurt you almost went over
my foot but what do you mean i almost
went over your foot
[Laughter]
well because you pushed the ottoman and
my oh that was your foot yeah see
i thought i was getting run over no tell
us about this outfit
well
since i was up so early i went to target
and um yeah you've been doing that she's
been doing like these target uh outfits
daily outfits
and like you know trying to go viral as
the target fashionista
i'm just having fun
you're doing a good job babe um
i know you don't like my outfit today no
i just it's just leather pants i'm not
i've never
okay they're like
um what's this color plum plum or
like burgundy
yeah and they're kind of like
pleather pants yeah they're pleather
it's fine
it's fine listen well i don't know if
i'd wear them out in public but like
what are you talking about you look nice
you said you wanted me on your podcast
and so i was like inspired to like get
something formal but yet like
would pop on the camera
[Laughter]
and then i also got you this shirt yeah
i like this shirt rachel gets a lot
rachel gets my shirts now that's part of
being married which i like yeah listen
rachel this is my 200th episode and i
will be 200. yeah i was like
not that i didn't want you on i'm just
saying i had i was looking to get like
all these
big guests i asked all these like you
know famous friends of mine everybody
was busy and stuff then i thought to
myself
what is supposed to be special and what
more what could be more special than my
beautiful
new wife so that's why you're here
sorry guys what do you mean
could have been a celebrity it could
have been someone funny
[Laughter]
well he was all reliable everybody
okay well i didn't mean it like that but
i guess
first of all
we had we already tried to record and
the thing wasn't on and i said it way
sweeter and she was all nice about it
but because we had to do it again it
didn't have the same you know what i
mean but you know i meant to no it
sounded the same the first time i just
like see when the cameras come on now
you want us now you want to like act up
this is your this is a podcast rachel
right now so acting up is speaking up
see here we go
i'm just saying i didn't think that was
like a crazy response to like your intro
okay
this is yeah okay well how do you feel
for 200 episodes well i was feeling good
maybe two minutes ago
[Laughter]
no i'm feeling fine it's you know it's
great you know whatever how does it make
you feel i wanted to do it down here
because it's like uh you know rachel
i don't know when last before she was on
before
you know we had a whole thing about my
old couch that she hated
she even made a instagram account i hate
my boyfriend's couch
i'm gonna make a new account called i
hate my boyfriend's nightstand
okay first of all we got a new
you don't like wow
i
i went to wayfair yeah wayfair
stop don't start they could be a sponsor
you never know i went to wayfair and i
got one i wanted a first of all it's
really hard to find nightstands first of
all i've never got anything good from
wayfair
then why did you have it on the registry
because you said you wanted furniture
and stuff like that no i didn't i did
not say that
you guys should see some of the things
rachel has on the radio registry all my
friends are clowning me rachel got eight
thousand dollar furniture on the
registry did you think someone was gonna
buy that
i mean
maybe i was thinking i was thinking
maybe
but then i was also with registries like
anything you put on the registry at most
companies like they'll give you a
discount after your wedding or like a
few months after so then you can buy
whatever is left over oh so that's what
i was thinking i was thinking with like
a 30 discount maybe we could get the 8
000
so you think we was gonna get we was
gonna spend what yeah what six or five
furniture is actually very expensive i
know this yeah this couch at least good
furniture is exceptional
couch right i love this couch yeah you
know what i actually love the couch too
better than the other that's right i
have nothing even to say about the couch
i love it so much i sleep on this couch
sometimes when i get
i get home and i don't want to go right
upstairs and wake her up because she's
switched her work schedule
she's like she's working early now and
so like i uh come down here and i'm
watching tv then i just fall asleep i'm
like oh man
it's great yeah you didn't like my couch
um
yeah well it's hard to find nightstands
right
yeah
or
we were looking for like tall furniture
well we had a whole issue because we had
a really tall bed
look we got a we got a mattress from
helix sleep i don't even know if they're
a sponsor this episode they could
possibly be damn i wish i had my phone
is that my phone or your phone
oh man where's my phone so i could find
out
um
like you tell them about the the well i
go get my phone you tell them about the
mattress situation
so
i didn't mention the mattress situation
to anyone before
because he was always embarrassed for
some reason
so
but
okay so we had his old mattress that i
made him get when i first met him i said
if you don't get a new mattress i'm not
sleeping over
so we got a new mattress so then when we
moved to this new place he brought that
mattress with him even though it was
like already like
what three years old
four years old mattresses have 10-year
warranties meaning people think they're
going to keep them okay so
well we were together for like
five years so it was like
five years old
and then he got sponsored by helix
mattress so they sent him a mattress so
it was in a box for like months
and it was also in my the other room
that we have that i used as a yoga room
for a little bit
and i couldn't go in that room because
that
big box of mattress was in there i don't
know how to explain it it was just like
a big mattress box and so i finally made
him open the box
take out the mattress and put it
upstairs but what he did
is he surprised me and put the mattress
on top of the other mattress so he had
and it made it
[Laughter]
it was like two mattresses that i felt
like it was super comfortable at first
but then you know oh my god it was a
little
fun which is like why like i kept it
there for so long because i knew like it
was it was kind of fun and like i knew
you enjoyed it so much and but then like
the night stands were like lower than
the mattress
yeah it was a whole thing you know and
you know what's funny helix sleep
actually is
a sponsor
of the
show
and so you like the helix sleep mattress
though right
yeah so i made him take out the other
mattress and so we have that mattress
sitting against her wall right now in
the hallway
and so now we're just sleeping on the
helix mattress but i feel like it was
destroyed in that process of like
like having the bed shake every five
seconds
and like with
you're like
a plus
model
here we go with the fat jokes on my own
podcast but listen guys helix sleep it
is a great mattress you get to like so
we're actually going to get another one
and rachel did the sleep quiz this time
because i did the sleep quiz last time
because i'm a side sleeper so rachel has
suggested now that hey you're bigger and
then like i think so because what
happens is my side of the mattress
starts to like you know sinking in he
starts to sink in you know so my
mattress stays up high and then we end
up colliding at night yeah she likes to
sleep in the middle and take up the
whole bed but helix
a lineup includes 14 unique mattresses
including a collection of luxury models
a mattress for big and tall sleepers
like myself and even a mattress made
just for kids so guys check it out helix
is offering up to 200 off on all
mattress orders two free pillows for our
listeners go to helix helixsleep.com
griffin with helix better sleep
starts now
ha see i snuck in a commercial
so anyways we but now we want now we
need new nightstands so now we have a
regular flat mattress we're going to get
another one um uh and then like so it's
hard to find a nightstand because here's
the thing i want i like the nightstand
with the cubby hole so like you know you
wanted the usb stick
right i want a smart thing on top that's
actually really hard to find or at a
reasonable price
well or you have to build it yourself
no
i like how you vague like vaguely want
to talk smack about me right now it's
nothing to do with you i could have paid
extra to have a building the wayfarer
nightstand well i went to wayfair and i
got a nightstand and i like you like it
too because you told me to get another
one
you see how you like you see you throw
me under the bus well i don't really
like it i'd rather get like furniture
that's already built that is like not
wobbly
but it is what it is you know and so
a new nightstand is a new nightstand at
the end of the day so
that's propel water yuck kiwi strawberry
who doesn't like kiwis strawberry
this guy
sorry it was for me so we've been
married four months now i think almost
right
what's your favorite part about being
married babe
well
a lot stayed the same but
my like
life kinda has changed
um i feel
like i don't know why
because it's
like you can't it's not like facts but i
feel like a little more secure
yeah yeah i know what you mean
like it's like that the thing that i
think it's like the feeling of like
thinking all right is this
are we really going to do this because
if not then there's like a little thing
in the back of your mind well then i
have to think about a different life and
so then once you put past that then it's
like this is our life we're moving
forward here we go so then it's like a
more relaxed calm
feeling
and then
i would say the sex is a little more
intimate
you know what i mean on our helix sleep
mattress go to helixsleep.com griffin um
and then um
what else that baby making sex
i literally
am
like
working harder at my job
or not harder but smarter yeah you're
doing good babe i want to tell you i
want to tell you publicly too just like
this is i think you're doing good i
think you know she's advancing in her
job and and rachel has a job because you
know to keep busy to have something to
do to have little spending money for
like all the creams and lotions and
pleather pants she likes to buy
you know but it's like but also now
she's like
advancing you're you're becoming a
visual merchandiser you're trying to get
leadership positions so but anyways it
affected you i feel you're like more
like she's super [ __ ] like you know what
i notice about you you're way more bossy
now
have you noticed that about yourself
yeah
like you're super bossy to me and i'm
like wow okay i don't i don't dislike it
actually because i'm my only child with
from a single mom so i'm used to you
know a woman being all like hey do this
do that do this and now you're all like
you know hey eric
wash your face take a shower before bed
and
all these things are you making me do
and i'm a better man for it
yeah i made you do laundry the other day
okay first of all we have an arrangement
okay
okay whatever i just thought oh you want
to bring that out okay no no you brought
it up so let's bring it up okay so you
want to talk about
should we talk about the things that i
do you want to bring it up
the things that i do no okay
yeah exactly
i wash the dishes
but i have to remove the dishes okay
because you use them okay two people and
we use every single fork in the bedroom
thing let's talk about the trash okay i
take the trash out
and leaves it
in the hallway
is not equivalent to taking it out to
the dumpster
and then you have to refill the bag
which is like a hard thing for you
but see
just how i put the dishes in the
dishwasher you take them out i take the
trash out and you put the trash bag in
the trash can okay so i'm doing two of
your jobs and i'm doing two of your jobs
what are you talking about it's teamwork
oh no it's teamwork rachel has a
sensitivity to smell even though i don't
believe her she's so dramatic like if
she's like she won't take the trash out
right
and then like if she smells sensitive
no that's like literal like body
reflexes
like i have no control over that yeah
but this is another thing you do you get
you you will get food
she'll eat the food half of it she won't
finish it she puts it in the
refrigerator if she let's say it's for
lunch if she doesn't eat that same food
for dinner the next day's in the fridge
now she don't want to have the leftovers
yeah because and then you leave it in
there though
and in the fridge in two two days the
fridge will stink up and then you go to
the fridge and you're like because
there's like an odor in the fridge that
so that's why you can't eat food that's
just staying in there because it's
probably infected with it oh my god
oh god woman i mean we have baking
what is it baking powder or baking soda
in there but yes sir
i think you're supposed to change it
every month and we don't oh i didn't
even know that that was in it that's all
you
yeah i got a refrigerator one oh well
i'll have to clean it up
no no because this is oh speaking of
this is like one of the things rachel
did was she got
on the registry she had to put a juicer
on the registry the juices i love the
juicer the juicer came and i said you
should return this because we're not
going to use it and then she was like oh
we're going to use it and then she goes
to the market and buys a bunch of
vegetables juices once doesn't clean it
okay oh i cleaned it you did not do too
and then now when's the last time you
juiced
i don't remember
[Laughter]
that
this is what she does too so when i say
oh you uh
you haven't juiced in a while and she
goes and buys vegetables
and then
it sits in the refrigerator they go bad
and then she opens the fridge like
you know something's in there and it's
her vegetables that she never juiced
yeah
we got a lot of stuff what do we got we
got a food processor a juicer a bread
maker bread maker when have you used
that
i didn't put that on the register yeah
you said you needed to make bread oh i
never said that
well we have a bread maker that we don't
you know we i hope that people that
send us some recipes
[Laughter]
we need the bread maker yeah
food processor and yeah we have a food
processor
what else what else the best gift we got
was to me it was from ben seaward shout
out to ben
um he got us to a new version of the
coffee machine because i'm such a coffee
snob now
and my favorite present was this silk
um
badge
what's it called a comforter yeah your
grandma comforter my grandma got from
boob from booby
booby got her uh i love it a silk thing
i never get to use it
she's always like get off my silk
blanket get off my blanket
well if you could get through the whole
night without farting
really rachel
[Laughter]
really really
i'll let you sit on it oh my god so i'm
the only one that farts in the family
huh
it's just me huh since we talking about
it
everyone knows girls part
secret oh my favorite was like her she
has a she follows a fart doctor on tick
tock
and i sent him the tick tock and it
actually said that
um guys and girls fart differently
right yeah it said like the guys um
fart
less
because girls are always farting nobody
said no no guys build what happens is
guys build up the gas and then they
release it like all at once
and girls are continuously farting all
the time we're leaking
all day
science
you can't point me out it's every woman
doing this i think he was specifically
talking about you though
i think he said uh rachel griffin oh you
went to the thing today
oh yeah i went to the social security
well first i went to the dmv
and they told me i couldn't change my
name
until i went to the social security
office and no one talks about this no
one says oh you have to go to the social
security office when you get married and
the dmv to change your name you just
think you have to change your license
but um yeah but you have to change your
name wherever your name is i guess
it's such a weird thing but it's
actually like it's so
it's so weird how easy it is in a sense
that you get you go down to the the
county clerk and then when when you you
know get your marriage license you do
all that thing you have this paperwork
and then you have this marriage license
that comes in in the mail and that
marriage license is everything
yeah and
where is it where did you put it it's in
an envelope upstairs okay but it was it
honestly
having or like being a bride and going
through like everything we did with the
wedding it's almost like an identity
crisis a little bit because it's like i
changed my name i changed my
phone number i changed my address and
then i'm like
when people ask me i'm like um let me
look it up to make sure
that's right i'm telling you correctly
and then they look at me weird like i
don't know my phone number
or like my address and it's like no it
just all changed like well you've been
living here for a while though but you
still you it's just when you still have
your address from from other things from
when you were living and then you
realize how many things you need to
change
even nowadays
yeah then we had a whole automobile club
disagreement
because
rachel
has been a member well because she was
on she was on no no no no you're on your
father's account but i'm not on it i
haven't been on it for years yeah but
you rachel you can't you weren't 27
years ago you weren't driving okay but i
was a member of 27 years on and that's
what it says
on my okay triple a card and that's what
any time they answer their phone they're
like thanks for being a customer for 27
plus years okay here's the thing though
here's the thing eric thought his
membership was
superior what did you have
excuse me
you're not gonna no you're not gonna be
cutting me off yeah
i had the prime membership so i had a
gold card so like i can get like uh 200
miles of of of towing i have a better
service i would i just haven't been a
member for as long okay and so what
happened
what happened when we asked whose
membership was
better
okay this but
so eric is now a 27 plus
member okay
but
i also but they did say the service was
better on mine so i upgraded us to
so now it's combined
[Laughter]
you can't you weren't driving 27 years
ago so yeah so anyway
at five or six i went to the social
security office today it took
literally like 30 minutes to get through
because i was up so early i was there
like when it opened
and yeah rachel was up so because she
changed her so now she up super early
i'm dead sleepy i've been having 5 a.m
shifts and then i wake up at 3 30. yes i
am
sometimes i'm just getting in like you
know or like i get in
from the comedy store and then i'm down
here like you know sleeping or watching
tv or play a couple of video games
before i go to bed and then when i come
up it's like she's like i gotta get up
in 30 minutes
well
but you like it though right yeah i love
it i'm doing visual merchandising at the
store i work at and
um it's easier to get things done when
guests aren't in the store yeah when
there's no riff raff around you can do a
lot of stuff so like we've been
changing lights changing
like
super
doing super big projects
your phone is making noise i don't know
what to do about it yeah there you go
turn it off rachel said 75 alarms every
single day well i have 80d
so
that means i get distracted a lot
and i like have a hard time
with knowing time
how like the amount of time that goes by
like sometimes i don't know if it's been
an hour or like 10 minutes
so like by setting
i like learn i don't know if i saw this
on tick tock you probably did but i
probably did that if you set your alarm
10 minutes from each other so like
say like 10 o'clock and then 10 10 and
then 10 20 then 10 30 that gives you
enough time to get a little more sleep
without
um
like
with it with a snooze being like
six minutes loud like any less than that
you can't get into a
sleep mode well i like it
i i had to start doing it
because like she'll set an alarm for
like okay she'll go like the alarm goes
off and she'll be like okay i gotta make
my coffee now and i'm like damn well
that's different that's my calendar
i know but i'm saying but you'll set
alarms for them so you'll be like i
haven't been like wake up and then i'd
be like
now i that's my alarm for waking up this
is my alarm for i should be in the
shower already this is my alarm for i
have to get breakfast and and make
coffee and this is my alarm for i have
to get start heading to work and i'm
like damn and i'm like so now i'm i'm
trying to do the same thing and it
actually really is helpful to be like
you know to really keep yourself like on
a schedule like that because sometimes
you think oh i could just do it but then
things just slip by sometimes i forget i
have a show until someone like i see a
tweet and they're like on the show
tonight eric griffin and i'm like oh man
i got a show tonight and then i have to
like take off so it's like it's good to
like keep things in the alarm and uh
but i just don't like notifications
going off like i don't like that i don't
like the thing buzzing all day and
beeping all day and all that kind of
stuff so that's the other thing too is
like i have to make it buzz louder if
i'm gonna do that because i don't want
the notifications on i hate that because
i'm on stage and like you know i'm doing
stuff i'm gaming or i'm doing the the
podcast and i just don't want that
notifications going off
you like it you just your her phone is
moving it's not that i like it i really
need it like i need
like
with california law you have to take a
lunch like before your fifth hour so
like if i don't have that alarm set i
might work over five you know over five
hours and then get fired or you know
like not take my break
or like not
that yeah
and so like it keeps me
like
you know i have an alarm right before i
have to leave so then like it's like oh
okay i gotta go
you know otherwise like if i look at my
clock and i'm like 20 minutes over
then i mean i don't think they'd
care that much because they like me
working there but
especially with a little
don't
no
i got this
i saw
there's this like
tick tock famous sorority girl
and like she wore her sweatshirt like
this
you know what do you think about it it's
like it's almost like a girl scouts like
you're setting me up right now okay
you know
don't be like how does this look it
looks good you look great i like it
but you always like you know this shirt
i like this shirt that you got for me
well you look really good in red so like
they haven't been selling a lot of red
stuff and then i saw it today and
i was like that's close enough it won't
match my outfit
actually i got your shirt before i got
my outfit i was kind of trying to match
you oh but then it just went off the
rails
it all kind of matches
it's like your shirt is like when it's
weird
we're in the same tone i like it
i like it well thanks for having me on
oh that's it for you
you just signed it off the podcast now
no i was just i felt like you felt like
that was it no i we could keep talking
no that's it for her she's done
that's it rachel's like thanks for
having me on the podcast
all right well this is about mrs griffin
um officially changed and that was your
choice i i i didn't make her do that i
asked if hey do you want to do that and
you were like yeah
but now we're i'm eg and she's rgg
and if we what does that mean for you i
just i think that we should keep that
going
it's like it's like it's like if we have
a kid it should be like like if we named
our kid you know leon it should be leon
gregory griffin you know so lgg i'm not
naming anyone gregory
it's a middle name
my middle name's graham so it's like
your middle name's greta yeah it's like
we want to keep let's keep the g what do
you guys think shouldn't we keep the g
going no
every person is unique and it's going to
be a new person and they don't need that
position
you're jewish
you you people are all about traditions
yeah we our traditions and names is we
carry on
like someone from our family we loved
and we um
name it after that person that who's
died
so
say like my my grandfather wilford
everyone called him wolfy
and like i would like the name wolfie we
are not naming our judge okay
wolfy okay also like my grandma rose or
my grandfather harold
these are all old school okay well you
see i was upgraded like i was named
after my grandma rose and by
they kept the first letter of her name r
so i alright so i wasn't in a row
but i like rachel you mean like g
so we could keep this the same side with
the g name
you don't know that so don't bring
religion in this
if you don't want to go by it
i'm just saying okay i think well i'm
going to put a poll up and we're going
to see your poll isn't gonna name our
kids
but good try can we have like some weird
like you know we have to have some weird
kanye names like you know like north and
you know well actually if we're talking
about
kardashian names is her kidnapping kylie
i just realized
north west yeah oh no
yeah realize that like the
pole
ugh okay well
what we don't have a kid don't
we're not having a baby right now we're
trying we want to right
yeah but i think we should wait to start
naming people when they're
almost here or
you know yeah but if we're gonna fight
about it now we should get this all out
okay
well do you think
the kid needs a g middle name thank you
that's what we're going to find out
where they'll put the poll up should our
kid have a g name like graham greta i
didn't like because
until i was like an adult and i realized
how unique it was but like thank you at
the time like yeah because you're a
rebellious no because when you go to
school here we go
you want the same name as everyone else
didn't you like change your name when
you were a kid you made everybody call
you something what julie
there were like
three rachel's all in my first grade
class could you change your name to
julie
yeah they would
they would always like get into trouble
and then the teacher would say rachel
and then she never met me never and so i
would always like turn and be like
what and then it was never for me so i
just changed my name real quick
on the paper
and i would just like write truly
and
i i think i went by julie for like a
year
let's name our dog if we have a daughter
julie but with a g no
ghoulie
it's all about the pronunciation ghoulie
oh that would be terrible
imagine your name imagine your name is
ghoulie well it just makes me think of
that abercrombie brand gilly hicks it
was like their lingerie brand oh
gilly hicks yeah
you never heard of it
is that the promenade
all right well everybody
i have rachel more often in the 200
blocks of the episode we'll do it just
like this from the couch this is uh
a version of i hate my boyfriend's couch
i know but it's just a name because it
might be the next thing she hates it'll
be like i hate my
boyfriends what stan my nightstand so
we're going to work on getting a new
knife or a refrigerator
yeah but that's or washer and dryer
you don't like the washer and dryer
no i i want a new one
uh rachel and i want to water thanks for
being here babe bye
oh yeah she wants a 3 000 water machine
everyone's posting about it
i learned about it
of course you learned about it on tick
tock all right wow thanks for watching
uh well no i'm not we're not done yet
with the episode i'm coming back right
now because i'm live uh this isn't live
but i'm live and this is rachel griffin
eric griffin babe anything you want to
say happy 200th episode love you baby
love you
yeah
so we did it y'all
all right man i want to thank everybody
for watching and we're from with griffin
you know this has been roofing with
griffin episode 200 with uh mrs griffin
uh like i say as always make sure you
subscribe uh make sure you uh
you know hit the notifications and all
that thanks for all the super chats and
all that kind of stuff
uh make sure you know i'm on twitch i'm
also on patreon you can like support me
any of those kind of ways i appreciate
you guys being here
um and if you want to send me a beat
for the rap recap
oh that's it
this is one of my old school beats
with the rap recap
step
[Music]
all
for the right this podcast is
200 episodes see you next year
let's see who won yes the g tradition
let's keep it going
thanks for being here everybody
and i will see you
next week
move your feet
okay
[Music]
while i pick up these sticks
bye see you next week
[Music]
you